socialist Senator Bernie Sanders May
hate capitalism but that has not stopped
him from occasionally cashing in
are you a capitalist no the Democratic
socialism the Democratic Socialist
curmudgeon is charging Bernie Fanatics
up to a hundred dollars a pop to hear
him take down capitalism tickets do come
with a copy of his new book it's okay to
be angry about capitalism which
incidentally costs 28 and as you can
imagine Bernie's colleagues in Congress
were quick to call out the irony now
Dana I hear uh it's just spiraling your
eyes it's gross I'm Vis I'm verbally
rolling my eyes yeah so he's a walking
advertisement for why the left is full
of crap this is ridiculous he has made
do you remember when uh Hillary was
going after him and he they had that ad
about Millionaires and billionaires and
then they changed it to just
billionaires why did they do that
because Bernie became a millionaire and
he could no longer say that it's just
crazy it's okay it's okay to earn money
on your book like didn't he start off as
a writer he did I mean erotic fiction
he's come a long way she's come a long
way no him too what are the guys allowed
is he not Greg to have three homes yes
everybody should have three homes I'm
all for it yes each one for your Hummer
you know the tickets should be free or
very least he should force half his
audience to pay for the tickets of the
other half or get or maybe or maybe 20
should pay for the remaining 80 so the
prices are like 500 bucks per person and
everyone else is free so the people that
paid the 500 bucks have to be next to
like eight people that didn't pay at all
and listen to them but what's most
disgraceful about this he's working with
Ticketmaster this is 2023. Ticket Master
what does that is slaves
Bernie I guess you don't care about race
anymore do you okay here's the thing you
can watch him for free all day on C-Span
so why would you bother to pay the 95
and if you think about it if minimum
wage is something like 17 you literally
have to work the whole day to pay to
watch him give a speech I mean none of
it makes sense it's the classic
hypocrisy the judge brings up minimum
wage you don't think the minimum wage is
adequate do you the federal minimum wage
always 7.25 cents an hour shouldn't it
be more than double that I don't know
isn't Bernie Sanders right
her the most honest thing Jessie's ever
said let's ask Fox Business about the
minimum wage this tells me the left is
on the March first Warren comes after
Kamala and then a day later Bernie
launches a book and goes on tour when
you do that you're running for president
so he's running for president we're
going to have to send Johnny to the book
tour to ask these people questions about
paying a hundred dollars
but it's okay to be angry about
capitalism but what's he going to
replace it with Bernie what does he want
to replace it with socialism we had
socialism during the pandemic I bring
you back Pfizer got rich and insurance
companies got rich I'll bring you back
to his point about the minimum wage
the fact that a federal government of
the United States of America has a 7.25
minimum wage that is a slave wage even
17 an hour is only thirty five thousand
dollars a year why doesn't Joe raise it
so I I think that despite the fact that
he well with your brother why doesn't
Joe raise it yeah
well do you think the Republicans who
cares
for two years another honestly
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now